1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
salut à tous nous mais leur sujet et
aujourd'hui une fois encore nous allons
parler de disney tout le monde aime 19
n'est pas qu'une seule personne au monde
qui n'aiment pas disney même hitler il
aimait disney cette ambiance magique ses
personnages attachants ces moments de
joie mais aussi des moments tristes des
chansons qui restent dans les mémoires
et ce parc génial avec des hôtels
beaucoup trop cher [ __ ] ya quelques
temps je me promenais dans un salon et
je suis tombé sur ce coffret ce que je
ne savais pas c'est qu'il allait changer
ma vie je pensais trouver du cuivre mais
j'ai trouvé de l'or donc le roi lion
simba je vous lis sa description
suite à la mort de son père simba se
doit de reprendre le trône afin de
devenir le roi de la savane
jusque là ça va pour l'aider dans son
périple des faits lui confie le pouvoir
de la grande ourse
notre jeune lionceau entouré de son
fidèle ami bimbo jeune faon destiné à
devenir le roi de la forêt alors ces
bandits c'est juste qu'ils n'ont pas osé
mettre le nom mais aussi de bagheera bas
look et bien d'autres rencontreront de
nombreux dangers et devront déjouer les
nombreux pièges du vil tigre shere khan
pour 2 732 du coup bah je suis fini
trois ans wayne rooney en trois ans
ce type de protocole et les v nations à
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
alors oui je sais vous allez me dire que
disney ont eux-mêmes pomper le roi léo
un l'oeuvre japonaise pour créer le roi
lion mais rappelez-vous la loi dit que
si vous avez plus de succès que l'oeuvre
originale ce n'est pas du plagiat
alors au passage pour comprendre ce qui
se passe ici je dois vous expliquer ce
qu'est le mc eu le marvel cinématiques
unis versent dans le monde aux
cinématiques univers
[Musique]
il faut savoir que mon dos world les
gens qui ont créé ce dessin animé on
commençait en diffusant des séries italo
japonaise dans les années 80 des séries
comme le livre de la jungle ou robin des
bois qui sont clairement japonaise se
voit c'est vachement mieux fait et qui
parleront certainement à tous les gens
de ma génération et même aux plus jeunes
car elles ont été rediffusés sur plein
de chaînes en france
[Musique]
suite à ces séries peut-être parce qu'il
n'avait plus de budget monde au work is
en bas tu es complètement les coups ils
ont décidé de faire des suite non
officielle animer ce coup-ci en europe
mais en faisant croire qu'il s'agissait
des mêmes personnages sauf que bon vous
pouvez le voir un lien ce que tu attends
veille à ce que tu as et pour pas en
rester là ils ont aussi commencé à
croiser les séries entre elles c'est
comme ça qu'on se retrouve dans le monde
du livre de la jungle avec bâle ou shere
khan et bagheera sur lequel on va
greffer d'autres personnages comme bambi
ou simba et ça vaut pour toutes leurs
séries puisqu'on va aussi trouver des
versions leader price ed personnage de
robin des bois de disney dans la belle
au bois dormant ou le prince de la belle
au bois dormant qui dans une autre série
va aller se battre contre des dinosaures
et des chiens en armure
bref c'est comme ça qu'on aboutit à
cette série du roi lion x le livre de la
jungle etc ont abouti à la naissance du
monde aux cinématiques univers ce rêve
cette série intitulée le roi lion simba
est également produite par la firme mon
dos et réalisé par un coréen intitulée
kim jong hockey qui n'en est pas à son
premier coup puisqu'il avait déjà
également pompe et mulan pocahontas où
la belle au bois dormant et aux
dernières nouvelles ce type a réalisé un
film intitulé la reine des avaleuse
en 2011 qui est un film pour enfants je
vous jure bref l'épisode eu de simba le
roi lion commence donc par le père de
simba que nous appellerons bout faso qui
se fait abattre par des chasseurs d'une
balle en pleine tête
mais heureusement ça devait être une
balle de tennis parce que des heures
plus tard ils agonisent toujours
et d'ailleurs pourquoi les chasseurs il
aura battu sion si c'est pas pour le
récupérer comme trophée après oman ce
sac j'ai oublié évidemment devant la
mort du roi tous les animaux de la forêt
pleure sa disparition nous enseignerons
hatefi ça est très chargé courageux
comme toi et celle très très belle
imitation de loups alors habituez vous à
ça parce que cette série a eu
l'excellente idée de faire redoubler les
cris d'animaux par les doubleurs et
maintenant attention le léopard
[Musique]
mais rebondissement le chasseur qui
avait abattu bout faso avait été en fait
guider la par sherkhan le méchant tigre
de la jungle
du coup les autres animaux décide que
les enfants de mou faso les lionceaux
seront élevés par la louve parce que il
me semble que vous les loups est les
meilleurs éducateurs tamniès a déjà
élevé mougli le petit d'homme avec jules
chèque
au passage je fais un aparté mais c'est
fou comment cette série elle est moche
[ __ ] chaque fois que tu fais un arrêt
sur image dans cette série tu tombes sur
un truc horrible
ouais j'ai aucune idée de ce que je fous
là - bref donc les animaux retrouvent
simba qui s'était endormi sur une mine
visiblement et l'aide en sortir grâce à
un bâton et c'est là qu'il apprend la
mort de son père tu as eu beaucoup de
chance sans bagheera tu serais mort
comme ton père le tact
qu'est ce que tu dis mon père est mon
notez à l'effort au papa au non papa des
nominés pour les meilleurs doublages
sont les changements pour le tri du
léopard
simba pour la mort de son père oh non
papa et la chouette dans la scène du
j'ai publié mon texte
alors je me je vais dormir c'est leur ai
dit vous qu'on est juste au tiers du
premier épisode alors je vais pas tout
détailler non plus parce que cette série
est tellement absurde qu'on pourrait
ouvrir une troisième chaîne juste pour
l'analyser notez d'ailleurs qu'il ya des
fautes d'orthographe dans tous les
titres l'épisode 2 s'appelle la file
mais je pense que c'était la fin
normalement l'épisode iii lui s'appelle
le le sexy même sens ok rien à voir avec
le sexe est évidemment
[Musique]
e
en fait le fun de cette série commence
vraiment à l'épisode 6 cols à rennes
défait cette bestiole là un vide simba
bambi et toute leur équipe d'animaux
pour donner à simba le pouvoir de la
grande ourse
du coup simba se retrouve avec des
pouvoirs avec la grande ourse gravé sur
le torse et wasquehal comme de kenshiro
et donc c'est quoi c'est pouvoir me
direz vous est ce que c'est la force la
sagesse un esprits clairvoyants non
maintenant simba peut tirer des [ __ ]
de rayons laser
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est mon cher rire bref donc
je vais accélérer un peu et on va sauter
quelques épisodes en avant jusqu'au
moment où la nature merveilleuse fait
son office
et voilà que comme dans le film le roi
lion simba est devenu grand et sa
conscience lui dicte d'enfin abandonné
sa croisade et de vivre en paix je suis
ta conscience je suis ton guide
ah non je déconne c'est le contraire
simba tu doit punir les coupables de
cette trahison
voilà ça c'est de la bonne morale pour
les enfants s'en suit une bataille entre
les animaux qui sort de nulle part juste
et qui en plus est ultra venerque 8ème
verte c'est pas pour rigoler la juste je
rappelle que tout ça là c'est juste
parce que si miles a entendu des voix
dans sa tête il dire de se venger ou
simba tu deviendras un très grand roi
sage et généreux non et la voilà le
monde étant père garder c'est beau la
paix quand même un [ __ ] je te connais
je pensais pas qu'elle est vraiment le
faire bref et la simba se met à pleurer
ses larmes se répand sur le sol ce qui
fait refleurir la plaine et ça lui donne
une folle envie de ce talk et j'ai pas
un chameau rasé je pense hélas vous le
voyez veux dire c'est parti pour la
version leader price de la scène d'amour
du roi lion
[Musique]
nous
m
et ici
sans tout
ça cher payé
en ski
cette série n'a aucun sens
comment se rattraper toute cette
incohérence
on s'en fout regardez je sais vous
voulez quoi
non mais [ __ ] ok on peut voler des
lions vous voulez pas la remettre le
capot rouge et en collier
[Musique]
oui simmbad trouve
une cape magique cette cave qui au
passage était cachée dans le cul dollars
mais bon ça c'est un détail mais au fait
je vous ai pas dit qu'il faisait des
rayons laser avec les yeux aussi
oui désolé je peux pas penser à tous les
détails j'aime beaucoup comment l'arbre
décrit le manteau 1 c'est un manteau
magie qui rend invisible celui qui le
porte
moi qui protège aussi ses amis dans un
rayon de 10 mètres à yaobou dit bon ça
peut pas être plus con mais si dans
l'épisode 30 simba qui tire des rayons
laser avec sa cape magique je rappelle
trouve un nouveau spot un [ __ ] de
dinosaures qui tire des rayons laser le
bronze
je suis même plus choqué qu'un animal
tirs des rayons laser dans cette série
de toute façon au bout d'un moment ça va
quoi la série est tellement de la merde
que ça arrive un coin de système
[Musique]
les tricératops bouneau ça n'est pas un
tricératops les tricératops ce n'est pas
carnivore et ça fait pas des cris de
cougar [ __ ] bon alors je saute
directement jusqu'à la fin les deux
souris pirates elles ont maintenant un
médaillon magique qui leur permet de se
téléporter et les enfants de ciba
peuvent voir le futur va [ __ ] ta mère
ainsi pu dévoiler le mystère du
médaillon de râ thèse 2 permettant de se
déplacer en moins de temps qu'il ne faut
pour le dire
tine et xl font bon usage de leurs
pouvoirs magiques et un jour peut-être
que les petits de simba et de bimbo
vivront des aventures aussi palpitante
que celles de leurs pairs et tu crois
pas si bien dire gertrude parce que
cette série a eu une suite avec les
enfants ne sais pas alors qu'est ce que
ça va être ce que ça va être les
aventures de simba junior pour rester
roi de la savane nouvel ennemi comme
sherkan non c'est les aventures de simba
junior à la coupe du monde de football
et vous savez on n'est pas dans un monde
il n'ya pas d'humeur auquel cas j'aurais
dit c'est un mot-clé uniquement peuplé
d'animaux donc il ya une certaine
logique
ah non mais parce qu'il y en a des
humains on envoie plusieurs fois dans la
série moment c'est juste des animaux qui
joue au [ __ ] le football et on s'en
bat les couilles
mais vous savez quoi eh bien je dirais
pas de mal de cette série parce que la
france est deuxième
[Musique]
allez mourir là au moment de world est
très malin c'est qu'ils se sont toujours
débrouillés pour coller la programmation
de leurs séries juste après celle du 10
mai correspond dans le roi lion sort en
94 simba le roi lion sort en 95% à 195
et la version de monde au world poker
entassent princesse des indiens
d'amérique sort en 96 et des chiffres
à pocahontas cette jeune indienne qui a
rencontré john smith et qui est parti en
angleterre et qui s'est fait violer par
tout l'équipage pendant le trajet mais
bon ça c'est pas dans le dessin animé
personnellement j'avais beaucoup aimé le
disney sur pocahontas notamment la
chanson des sauvages qui est je trouve
une des chansons les plus osées pour un
disney avec des paroles très fortes
donc comme je disais un an après la
sortie du film de chedid et monde world
emboîte le pas avec sa propre série
pocahontas
alors est ce que ça sera comme dans le
film disney 1 on pourrait supposer que
ce sera ça puisqu'on le voit dans la
description ses marques et blabla elle
épouse john smith et part à londres pour
donner un message roi etc et bien
surprenamment non voilà le trajet de
pocahontas dans le film de disney ou en
vrai à petit même chose et voilà le
trajet de pocahontas dans la série mon
dos auld
[Musique]
c'était à droite john smith n'apparaît
pas une seconde dans toute la série et
les seules zones blanc que tu vois c'est
pendant un flashback de 10 secondes dans
le premier épisode
ces [ __ ] d'hommes blancs qui rigole
dans des charrettes et enterrent des
animaux vivants ouais parce que ouais
bref alors l'histoire commence on suit
le jeune opio de la tribu aux pies qui
alors qu'il rentrait chez lui voit des
lumières apparaître devant lui ce sont
celles des dieux indirects qui vienne
lui porter un message vital
puis que je t'ai transports c'est que
cette horreur
c'est quoi cette tête de l'ego mais
[ __ ] mais un effort merde
le personnage là on dirait qu'il se
retient de rire tellement que c'est
ridicule
non les cascina bienheureuse esprit de
ton peuple
nous observons depuis longtemps et nous
avons découvert mon costume
bref après avoir reçu sa mission des
dieux indiens hopis repart il doit se
rendre sans plus attendre dans le
village de pocahontas elle t'attend
jamais met en route
bref alors comme j'ai dit pourquoi on
tasse va naviguer à travers toute
l'amérique pour rencontrer toutes les
tribus une par une
alors on va pas vous détailler chaque
épisode est mais il y avait des épisodes
particulièrement dégueulasse
alors avant de vous le montrer déjà je
dois vous dire que cette série était
diffusée à la télé à l'heure où les
enfants regardent
c'était donc une série pour toute la
famille est cependant s'il ya des
enfants qui regardent actuellement cette
vidéo allez vous en je déconne pas
besoin c'est un épisode 17 pocahontas
tombe sur une autre tribu d'indiens qui
ont visiblement des traditions un petit
peu comment dire ok vraiment vous avez
une dernière chance de vous barrer parce
que je vous le dis vraiment ce n'est pas
quelque chose que vous avez envie de
voir
je ne plaisante pas ok
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas les tétons pas les tétons cette
scène dure 4 minutes 30
on a tous les gros plans sur les plaies
ouvertes les ralentis les gros plans sur
les visages qui se tordent de douleur
le sang qui tombe sur les pieds pas les
tétons pour toi je suis oui alors
pendant quelques secondes je me suis dit
que c'était peut-être un genre de vraies
traditions qui avait vraiment existé
donc je suis allé sur google et j'ai
tapé tétons et indien j'ai trouvé plein
de vidéos mais aucune vraiment
pertinente mais j'y crois toujours je
suis sûr qu'on va avoir au moins un
épisode réaliste mettez moi l'épisode
suivant
j'y crois encore
va te faire [ __ ]
l'épisode 18 et donc un épisode de
bataille
alors donc dans cette bataille pour
casque est la faculté de téléporter des
troupes depuis son cheval blanc à pois
rouges se bat contre visiblement la
tribu spider man qui tire des rayons
laser
vous adorez les lasers à vous mais
heureusement elle se fait aider par les
animaux de la forêt regardez les ils
arrivent qui eux aussi tirent des rayons
laser et par les nuages
tant côté havrais tous avec tous ses
pouvoirs à scier les indiens ils ont
perdu c'est qu'ils méritaient de perdre
bref donc la série philippaerts
pocahontas qui se retrouvent au mexique
et au pérou chez les mayas les aztèques
et les incas pour les prévenir de
l'arrivée des conquistadors ça marchait
alors vous allez me dire mais c'est pas
possible puisque pocahontas a vécu
techniquement cent ans plus tard que
toutes ces civilisations précolombiennes
ça c'est pas un problème
vous voyagerez dans le temps et donc
pour finir en beauté cette série pour
enfants
pocahontas assiste un sacrifice humain
voilà
bien
oh les meilleurs arbitres
oui
mais c'est vrai qu'on a fait énormément
de recherche sur le langage des aztèques
pour être le plus fidèle possible et on
a tout perdu
enfin oui c'est jean marc qui a tout
perdu 1
d'ailleurs je reviens à ce que je disais
au début mais vous avez aimé des
avengers
eh bien mon dos world aussi à ça et 15
ans avant que marvel est une idée
l'ultime série où tous les dessins
animés se croisent le monde aux
cinématiques unis versent à et quand je
dis tous s'est tous un c'est no limit
quoi donc on va avoir en vrac pocahontas
kitimat paris mullan aladin et les
tortues ninja
je ne plaisante pas je répète il ya un
chien à deux têtes un dinosaure moche un
ours geronimo le descendant de
pocahontas mullan aladdin hercule une
tortue ninja et david le [ __ ] de roi
des juifs qui se promènent cyr règles
géant bleu a je dis oui mais tait
absolument regarder le dernier cet
extrait du dernier épisode de la série
c'est le bordel
certes y'a plus de courir à lancer de
logique que cette série on dirait une
partie de fortes têtes sous acide
oui avocats de disney company vous êtes
accusé d'avoir plagié nos films veuillez
nous suivre
[Musique]
désolé je crois qu'on s'est trompé oh
[ __ ] c'était bon ou arrêter toulon
francs renew sais quoi je décerne
officiellement maintenant le titre de
meilleur chef du monde au monde aux
cinématiques unis versent
[Musique]
oui
il